so bill have started a new series asking
successful entrepreneurs what their
favorite books are what they recommend I
know every summer you go away and do a
little bit extra reading so I'm curious
what are you reading and what are your
recommendations for entrepreneurs every
summer I try to do a little extra
reading here's a few books I've read
recently that you might enjoy on
immunity by EULA Biss she explains the
history of vaccinations why children who
don't get vaccinated can even affect
those who are vaccinated she's a very
good writer I wish I could write as
nicely as she write should we meet by
Vaslav Smeal it's provocative the way he
does the title is though past the
responsibility to the reader where we
know it's pretty hard for people to give
up meat there are books that touch on
this topic that don't have numbers in
them but you know this is meal you are
gonna get the numbers you might even get
a few sentences in between the numbers
how do I with statistics by Daryl huff
being able to understand what you're
looking at and being willing to say hey
where did that come from is that
accurate it's a quick read it's got a
lot of good examples in it to trip to
the past even though the basic points it
makes or still is valid a what if by
Randall Munroe it's a very clever way of
getting you to think about various
scientific things going on this idea of
when you see a glass half-empty do you
mean empty as in perfect vacuum and you
know all of a sudden if there was a
glass sitting there where you put the
water on the top and the vacuum in the
bottom of the vacuum on the top and the
water on the bottom this is clever
those are the kind of questions that
somebody with a good mind who's trying
to figure out if they really understand
that's a kind of question you should ask
yourself hyperbole and a half my alley
broke she's pretty creative and humorous
about making fun of herself and
revealing her inner thoughts there was
one thing about the dog where this is
one that I told Melinda to read where
the dogs getting confused where they're
moving and so she's trying to simulate
what the dogs thinking
and her dog maybe it's true it's one of
the most inept impossible dogs to ever
take care of and finally the magic of
reality by Richard Dawkins and science
were all kids I mean a good scientist is
somebody who's redeveloped the chain of
reasoning of why we know what we know
from scratch many times just to see
where there's holes or alternate
possibilities could never hurt to reread
these things and think through what
you're learning we can observe way more
stuff than you'd imagine and we've made
more sense out of the stuff we can
observe than you can imagine
so quite a range there in terms of fun
to learn fun to know about I hope you
enjoy them as much as I did thank you so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed I
want to know if you have read any of
those books what you think of them if
you're planning on reading any of them
and I'm gonna add them to my Goodreads
list as well if you want to follow me
there and check out the other books that
we've profiled so far thank you guys so
much for watching and let me know what
you think in the comments
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon